What does this mean? Depending on our criteria for what constitutes likely or
unlikely if we get a sample mean in the critical region here for a one-tailed
test or here or here for a two-tailed test. Then we decide that most likely we
did not get this sample mean by chance. Note that in the case of a two-tailed
test. The z-critical values are the same used to calculate confidence
intervals, Here, you're just applying the same ideals to different situations.
When we do statistical test, we'll set our own criteria for making a decision,
in other words, we'll choose an alpha level. And then we'll decide that if the
probability of obtaining a particular sample mean is less than that alpha
level, Then there's evidence of an effect. Usually we're going to stick with an
alpha level of point zero five. At an alpha level of point zero five we have
two possible outcomes in either situation, one tailed or two tailed. Either the
sample mean will lie outside of the critical or inside the critical region. We
notate these two outcomes as the null hypothesis. Which we call h not or h sub
zero and the alternative hypothesis h sub a. Other ways of notating this could
be h sub one but I'll just stick with h sub a for alternative. The null
hypothesis assumes that there is not significant difference between the current
population parameters. And what will be the new population parameters after
some sort of intervention. So we'll notate it like current population parameter
mu is equal to the population parameters after the intervention, where when we
say equal, we don't mean exactly equal, we just mean they're not significantly
different. The alternative hypothesis guesses that there will be a significant
difference. Either the current population mean will be less than that after the
intervention, or the current population mean will be greater. Or that it'll
just be different, and we don't predict a direction of the treatment. For the
null hypothesis, when we're guessing that there's no significant difference
between these two parameters Our sample mean will lie somewhere outside the
critical region, in this white space. Note, also, that for a 1-tailed test the
critical region could be on the left tail, not just the right. And the
alternative hypothesis guesses that there is a significant difference, and that
means that our sample mean will lie somewhere in the critical region.